bom dia bom dia eu vou eu quero que
vocês técnica 15 10 segundos pensando
sobre esse tema o que é o lixo para você
quando você pensa em lixo o que você
pensa onde você vai
as pessoas que trabalham com lixo os
espaços que têm esse lixo aonde as suas
casas
os seus condomínios nas suas escolas
as duas empresas o seu balde está do
lado em cima da pia
o que é isso para você pra mim foi um
foi uma oportunidade para mim foi uma
oportunidade um desafio e quando você
pensa em lixo provavelmente a primeira
imagem emblemática que você vê é de um
lixão
mas se você bem essa foto não é o lixão
que incomoda o que está te incomodando
são pessoas são pessoas que estão
trabalhando
e sabe qual que é a igualdade deles que
estão lá e nós estamos aqui todos nós
produzimos lixo desde quando nascemos
até quando morremos
aliás nós quando morremos somos
classificados como revivido um cemitério
precisa de uma licença se deve então nós
somos revivido então e que aconteceu com
lixo na minha vida como tudo começou
eu morava em são carlos um condomínio
anterior de são paulo
eu pegava o lixo todo dia da pia
amarrada aquele lixo a um condomínio com
graminha na frente pegava aquele lixão
andava andava andava no fundo do
condomínio de uma lixeira e sem serviço
já que tiveram essa experiência homens
têm essa experiência
aí você abre um container geralmente vem
um impacto de odor você pega aquele
início joga tum tum e sai com um final
tem acontecido geralmente é assim que
você lida com o lixo né lixo uma coisa
que você está na sua vida desde que você
faz cocô na fralda até quando você morre
é como você vida como nós lidamos com
lixo e aí eu com esse problema dele de
morangos são carlos levando lixo século
vinte e um diretor de empresa eu falava
não é possível não é possível que a
índole sueste procedimento eu vou deixar
esse legado para os meus netos meus
filhos que absurdo não é possível em
2011 reúne a família falei gente
agora vamos mudar de vida de novo pai
esposo agora de novo agora que a coisa
se estabilizado então interior são
carlos é o melhor o melhor clima de são
paulo estava incomodando não posso
chegar com 50 anos e não fazer nada num
construir alguma coisa vão realizar um
sonho e esse sonho via martelando desde
o tempo de faculdade e faculdade formiga
grossa uma 30 anos atrás quando se
falava em permacultura em agricultura
orgânica aí se você é desviado no
caminho você vai trabalhar em muitos
lugares e perde um pouco da essência e
isso quando eu levei o lixo nessa
lixeira eu falei
ninguém vai fazer nada
aí vem o desafio é ótimo você tem um
desafio você tem desafio este movimento
é um desafio voltamos a estudar internet
um homem de 47 anos voltando a estudar
no interior
eu estava com livros da outra maneira de
estudo com menos informação então voltar
tanto informação como filtrar a tanta
informação tanta gente falando sobre
revendo e sustentabilidade em outros
países quando se começa a falar de
sustentabilidade
as pessoas falam nossa na alemanha é
lindo
nos estados unidos a disney é lindo
porque aqui não é lindo aqui no brasil
aí por que ou quem trabalha a
sustentabilidade em aí vendo isso eu fui
atrás da solução procurando várias
soluções entendendo a solução mais uma
solução pro revido gerado no brasil
vocês sabem que é resíduo orgânico
gerado na suécia na alemanha é um caroço
de azeitona aí falar e falar em
compostagem aquele prato de imóveis não
deixou nada além do fazer compostagem
assim vocês sabem que é fazer
compostagem trabalhar com resíduo
orgânico no brasil
a gente trabalha com sobras de arroz
feijão bife batatinha salada tomate e de
sobremesa laranja melancia abacaxi e
isso pra quem nutricionista já foi
restaurante e te dá um volume de resíduo
orgânico que é absurdo e nós temos uma
cultura também cobrar o brasil país a
fartura quando você vai em qualquer
lugar você vê o resíduo orgânico sobra
comida no nosso prato nosso filho é
criado aquelas obra de comida não quer
deixá lá fora e isso te dá um volume
dados estatísticos 51 por cento do lixo
gerado no brasil é orgânico
de cada 100 quilos e 51 quilos é
orgânico
aí junto com o apoio da família que deu
coragem que ofereceu essa opção a gente
mudar de vida com 47 anos
a gente veio para são paulo
mudamos para são paulo o que fazer para
começar um projeto 2010 estamos em 2011
e 2012 mudando para são paulo
isso já sem emprego vendendo turno
investindo tudo o que nós tínhamos uma
família tinha num novo projecto
e aí eu comecei a fazer trabalhos com
uma solução uma solução de resíduo
orgânico para lixo é chamada de
compostagem como fazer essa compostagem
aí a gente começou a trabalhar começou a
entender
aí eu falei agora com o tomo eu peguei
uma receita de bolo
aí eu falei agora eu tenho um composto
como falar para essas pessoas que essa
receita é boa
fazer vasos o manjericão debaixo do
braço foi fui bater de porta em porta
nos todos os grandes geradores
olha que eu sei fazer plantar manjericão
início olha que eu sei fazer contas e
louco louco sai daí não expande antes
sabe que eu resido a máfia do lixo ser
louco não vai fazer e aí em 2012 em 2012
deu a primeira oportunidade eu eu fui
uma grande empresa em são paulo um
grande shopping e um gerente de
operações foram ruim eu acredito isso eu
quero fazer isso aí eu farei meus
problemas estão resolvidos né
tive oportunidade em gana de vocês
começou o desafio uma coisa é você fazer
na sua casa ou em bancadas de
laboratório empresas de pesquisas cinco
quilos 10 quilos três folhas de alface
composto saindo uma coisa você chegar em
um grande gerador de resíduos que a lei
fala de um grande gerador chegar a 500
quilos de resíduos orgânico para você
tudo misturado você fala nossa que eu
vou fazer
então tivemos que entender uma gestão de
orgânico tite que entender esse grande
essa grande empresa que por por incrível
que pareça um shopping center que passa
40 mil pessoas por dia um milhão e
duzentas mil pessoas por mês e gera lixo
pra isso o que fazer
começou a oportunidade dez meses se
passaram dez meses se passaram e eu fui
entendendo fui entendendo que o lixo tem
tendo denominações em ter separação
quando trabalho com compostagem o que
vocês chamam de lixo ou resíduos
orgânico para mim a matéria prima uma
indústria de compostagem
você tem até chegar à matéria prima não
pode ser misturada com um papel com com
papel com garfo com vida
pedro que hora que você vai maneja e
quem operava era eu
eu senti essa dificuldade na mão então
você tem que fazer pra sentir porque eu
não vou mandar ninguém fazer isso não
possa fazer e depois de dez meses a
gente conseguiu ajeitar a fazer a
receita do bolo a gente tinha um
composto orgânico que lindo nossa em 15
dias 20 dias um composto sem cheiro
lindo que fazer para esse resíduo
orgânico o que fazer agora o lixo ficou
empreendimento o que eu vou fazer com
isso aí
junto com esse que me deu a oportunidade
que hoje é um grande amigo meu flow ruim
vamos fazer um telhado verde com lixo
com resíduo
eu já fui para boston já fui para nova
york e isso lá é lindo mas eu fui lá
alguma que ele faz um telhado verde eles
compram terra com um composto com para
as plantas americano alemão um telhado
verde é lindo
agora fazer com o lixo vamos começar a
fazer começamos a levar o composto na
cabeça são 100 degraus para quem conhece
já foi
não é fácil ninguém ninguém acreditava
se pegava que eles aquele composto subia
levava fazer o canteiro que é do tamanho
do círculo aí depois você faz um
canteiro tem que escolher a planta que
dá certo
também não é fácil pleno sol se a subir
em algum balaj um grande empreendimento
são paulo
acho que é tudo branquinho bonitinho
geralmente grandes embrenhem em presas
têm coifa pra cá coisa pra cá a torre de
ar condicionado para lá é uma condição
tão específica e aí a gente começou a
fazer esse canteiro e fizemos o primeiro
canteiro e se foi a primeira colheita do
primeiro canteiro de um telhado verde
feito com lixo no brasil shopping
esse é meu parceiro me ajudou muito
porque ele é da japonês japonês japonês
tem uma coisa com a agricultura é uma
referência como o agricultor né
e ele plantamos berinjela um pleno verão
berinjela em composto no meio do telhado
e aí na primeira colheita e também aí a
gente vai com leis como fazer
vamos subir todo empreendedor de bosa ar
condicionado
chegou lá essa pessoa a satisfação dele
de subir o fato no seu telhado e colheu
uma menina ela está o influente imagem
que foi nossa primeira colheita
nesta primeira colheita a gente começou
a crescer a gente desculpa a gente foi
crescendo e aí os projetos foram
aumentando dentro do projeto aqui tem um
projeto chamado feijoada na laje
a gente plantou feijão preto colheu
feijão preto e em fevereiro começou o
projeto para comer feijoada de inverno
para 400 colaboradores
então o a um telhado começou a ter nome
feijão na laje o tomate da laje
o chá de hortelã e aí
e aqui esse é o próximo e aí veio a
transformação do lixo
quando você fala em transformando lixo
em pó que faça né
mas pra mim isso não quer dizer nada
transformar lixo um composto é a parte
número 1 do projeto à parte número 2 que
eu mais me orgulho é essa aqui as
pessoas que estão trabalhando hoje e se
esse menino ex-motoboy eu falo sim se o
que você fazia antes quebrar o
retrovisor
hoje ele foi o primeiro auxiliar de
compostagem que a gente conseguiu
registrar como filhos de compostagem
olha a felicidade dele em cima do
telhado colhendo alface
se os dois estão no rio de janeiro eu
joseildo e o marcos limpava o banheiro
hoje estão no telhado e olha a
felicidade dessas pessoas trabalho
o pior início a gente não quer trabalhar
aqueles que os corpos se sabe o que
estou falando é de resto de arroz e
feijão aquela coisa e uma coisa que
também nos deu muito orgulho que a gente
conseguiu transformar espaços criar
novos espaços
aquele telhado era um ferro-velho ao céu
aberto
era uma fonte de dengue neste grande
empreendimento
hoje ele está totalmente nele
esses telhados são novos espaços que
você vai criando no mesmo empreendimento
e outra coisa criando espaços sem fazer
parede em um outro tipo de alternativa e
aqui no próprio dante
nós temos esse telhado que já está aqui
na cabeça dos senhores já existe alface
plantada e do início e do lixo parabéns
para o défice
quero que você olhar tudo uma coisa que
a gente nota que o desperdício é muito
as pessoas desperdiçam muito alimento
então a gente está fazendo um tratamento
de um lixo orgânico é ainda consegue
transformar a ele comida de novo pois
quem chama de um círculo com lívia
virando comida tá bom
isso é ser sustentável
a tinta é a criatividade que eles
tiveram e fazer isso daqui e que também
distribuirá gente então isso é uma coisa
muito boa
além deles a reaproveitar os alimentos
poderia ter sido jogado fora essa
oportunidade está criando isso daqui
streaming a gente né gente não paga à
risca a parte melhor
isso daí foi um vídeo que me deu uma uma
surpresa
depois o projeto foi implantado o
projeto a gente vai do projeto pois o
filho cresce anda sozinho
em termos de números civil foi assistido
por 2 milhões em 700 mil pessoas no
mundo um projeto criado no brasil que
ele põe o brasil com 11 mas no meu
brasil é com s
então queria deixar essa mensagem para
vocês e queria perguntar pra vocês
também
o que é isso para você obrigado